[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  i think it is important for disabled  artists  from from other other places to  to come to together  firstly  because  because they can  they can  exchange their  their experiences or maybe i should we  can change  our experience  we can  learn so much from each other  [Music]  mention mr long  but not my workshop scheme  well  [Music]  [Music]  as  a choreographer  i don't really see myself as a disabled  choreographer  i think what really surprised me there  are a lot of people who want to achieve  new things  that really  push themselves to achieve new things  and it's really nice to see what other  people do  [Music]  um  [Music]  [Music]  a  [Music]  you